i just
i don't even know what to say to this
guy he's a [ __ ]
you spread your legs i just think he's
an [ __ ] feminizing men and they're
masculinizing women instagram stories
are going to be coming soon with the
change.org and all the girls are going
to be political activists
so i know we've been watching a lot of
tate lately but now we're going to
switch it up there's another guy
trending on the internet of the name
sneko so this dude's been saying similar
stuff to tate for years but he's just
now catching a lot of traction because
the tape stuff is so popular so he has i
think 500 million views on tick tock
it's similar to what tate has where he
has tons of accounts just his minions
posting all his stuff so i only found
out about him a few weeks ago but i
really like what he has to say it's that
same alpha male mentality stuff that
tate has so it's pretty interesting yeah
he's 23 years old from new haven
connecticut so not too far and yeah
let's get right into it why would a high
value man with lots of options choose
you to be his one and only woman
because of this bomb ass [ __ ]
because i mean because look at us we're
baddies like we're bad as [ __ ] they all
think they're tense that's what i'm
talking about that's where the
frustration comes are you serious
we're just baddies they don't think that
they have any room for improvement we
tell girls you're perfect don't change
toxic i'm a capricorn they all think
they're perfect so they don't have to
develop any personality that's why when
you go on a date with them they just sit
there looking pretty and you need to
start all the conversation what are they
going to talk about besides keeping up
with the kardashian and lip fillers
genuinely what the [ __ ] are you going to
talk about and i'm wifey material why
are you wifey you don't know how to cook
you don't want to clean it's definitely
like an over simplification like an
oversimplified version of things like
not every woman just cares about the
kardashians and that [ __ ] but we
were just talking about that how men
definitely do think that they have more
room to improve than women they kind of
just think that they're more perfect
that they don't have to to prove as much
to men like how how could these girls be
like we're tens like we have
we deserve any high value man like come
on
that's absurd he's right about a lot of
this that's so ridiculous in fact it's
obviously broad strokes it's not all
women but these women or this one in
particular just had nothing of any
substance to say so you cannot high
value intelligent hardworking man brings
a lot to the table and it's because as a
man you actually need to have redeeming
features and you need to build traits
about yourself and a woman doesn't have
to do it women does for a high value man
she does i mean yeah you you see the
ones on tv like who marry the 80 year
old man who marries the 20 year old
but you know who has a p brain that's a
different story and that's unusual but
every man of substance that i know is
married to a really smart woman somebody
that can hold a conversation that can i
can keep up with them and that they're
proud of a loyal non-ho
a true teammate that they value i
wouldn't marry that girl either unless
she's got something a lot better to say
but if i was interviewed at her age god
knows what i might have said so yeah i'm
judging with with some with some years
ahead of her if you chase women you'll
eventually run out of money but if you
chase money you'll never run out of
women
honestly yeah because we want the money
they want your money and they have
nothing to give you
[Music]
and they got nothing
they're not funny they're not unique
they got nothing to give you but stinky
leech off you until you're broken that's
why look at the guy look at the guy
right here this is the face of a guy
who's had to deal with these nonsensical
women these women exist
again not all women but yes these women
exist and i don't know if this is a
generational thing or maybe there's more
of them like that now because of the
internet because of the depression that
the internet causes because of the
competition that it causes and everybody
feels bad about their lives so they want
to go with money so they can get that
fancy purse and feel good about
themselves for five seconds i don't know
maybe it isn't maybe is that really what
you're up against out there
it's tough out here mom it's tough out
here it was tough when i was a kid i
feel so bad if it's worse for you
it's horrible you want some meatballs
i'll make you some meatballs that'd be
nice those nowadays do absolutely
nothing and feel special absolutely
nothing the same copy and paste
personality
period
but i bring home
you know back in the day
we didn't act like that you know women
were
were high value they brought something
to the table this
this depiction that he's saying you know
the
woman who just thinks that you know
she's gonna snap
is
a sect of society that exists and i'm
embarrassed for them and i want to take
every one of them ahead and go
sweetheart you got a couple minutes can
we talk
you know straighten her out a little why
do you care so much about abortion
because you don't even you can't get
pregnant
yeah but our our mothers our sisters our
female friends our future daughters um
they want your mom to get an abortion
uh honestly yeah it would have been
great what life isn't the best man but
you wish your mom got an abortion
um
yeah honestly yeah cause like i didn't
consent to be born
i don't even know what to say to this
guy he's a [ __ ] i didn't consent to
being born in that case doesn't the baby
not consent to being killed oh good
point i don't know life isn't the best i
wish my mother may life isn't the best i
only grew up in the time where dude 200
years ago you had to fight [ __ ] saber
to tigers and you're here talking about
this you like how could you not see how
previously privileged you are that's
that's like absolutely ridiculous i
don't even know what to say yeah what
happened his life imagine what his
parents went through to get this guy
here that's embarrassing right if i if i
ever heard you talk like that
that's just sad your mom held you for
nine months for that that's just sad i
was gonna make an abortion joke but i'm
just gonna kill that baby right there
i don't think that's funny
smiling a little bit
yeah because you still made a joke
i think that's funny that you didn't
stop making the joke
slavery's good
hell yeah i got a confederate flag in my
crib bro i'm waiting for that [ __ ] to
come back some of these [ __ ] really
need to get the feels bro like i don't
know how i feel about that one i don't
get the whole confederate flag stuff i
get like it's history but it's like bro
at the end of the day the real thing
everyone thinks about when seeing the
confederate flag is slavery so it's like
what are you trying to prove by putting
that up yeah what's the point i i
personally don't understand that i
haven't had a conversation with a truly
educated southerner that can explain to
me what the
what the point is of the flag i think i
think you know like what everyone
everyone's thinking when you see the
confederate flag about slavery like
they're not thinking about the history
or all that [ __ ] that people try to
that people try to say you know yeah it
it i i think that's by association i
think that guy might have been joking
but i'm just talking about it
it's guilty by association it's just
weird yeah the flag do you think it's
okay to be fat
oh yeah i love fat women
yeah that's your preference no no no my
preference is women who like me back
and that tends to be fat women
nine out of 18 times yeah
9 out of 18 times yeah i just use that
fraction because that's my body count he
has like a notes tab of all the fat
[ __ ] he's hooked up with and their
weights next to it is it okay to be fat
of course it is okay it's not and it's
okay to feel good about yourself and
your fat but it's not okay what they're
doing now in pop society is pretending
like it's awesome to be fat they're
completely forgetting about diabetes and
heart disease and
isn't heart disease the leading the
leading factor of death in the united
states i'm pretty sure it's the number
one death cause it's in the top three so
yeah it's close i don't even really
think it's i think it's like okay to be
fat like you shouldn't like lose rights
but you shouldn't want to be fat like if
you're fat are you okay with being fat
just go to the gym i don't get it you
feel so much better by just making
yourself look look good so why wouldn't
you do it it's just about looks it's
really just about strength and stamina
and energy i think i mean you know
everybody doesn't have your face kiddo
oh yeah some people they can get skinny
and honest
i try to improve every day so if i even
like i'm i'm pretty skinny and i'm
trying to put on muscle like i don't
know i feel like it's kind of weird just
being okay with being fat i don't know i
just shouldn't be promoted to be they're
going too far like they do everything
they're going too far in the other
direction and saying it's gorgeous and
wonderful to be four hundred pounds yeah
when you die at 40 from a heart attack
and you have to have a [ __ ] crane
take you out the front window so you can
go to the hospital like because you
can't fit through the door like that
actually happened you saw that right
i've been with a lot of girls who like
who don't even try to do basic hygiene
like they they aggressively don't shave
their pits because they don't feel like
you know
that's so disgusting it's such it's such
a kill for girls when they do that and
they're trying to make like a statement
i don't need to shave my kids to get men
you know in other parts of the world
they don't and then in like really
hippie communities here in the u.s they
did it because they were just being all
natural and i never understood then i
don't understand it now and i will
till the end of time advocate for women
to shave their armpits i don't even
think it's like good for guys to have a
lot of armpit hair i mean i trim mine a
little it should be trimmed it shouldn't
be it's not it's not sanitary to have it
it's not even like it actually it
actually it you can look it up and if
you have the hair helps to house and
develop bacteria so that's why you smell
more at the end of the day yeah when we
were we went me and my friends went to
miami
um one of the first weeks of school and
we were staying at this girl's house
that my friends was friends with and
there was this beautiful girl like one
of the girl's friends was oh my god like
a nine out of ten
but she had
we're laying on the bed and she goes
like this and she has full hit of arm
hit of arm hair i i couldn't even i
didn't even know what to say me and my
friends are just in shock you know the
truth is pretty girls have it hard as it
is because so many guys are free to talk
to them so pretty girls are actually the
loneliest girls if you see a pretty girl
you want to talk to her go up and talk
to her but then she does that that's
totally true it's true what if like the
girl that you're hanging out with is
just way the [ __ ] out of your league
right there's absolutely no chance you
can stop stop saying she
stop there's no such thing as leagues
stop it
oh okay oh there's no elaborate that's
the mentality bro leagues is something
that women made up you know what league
is is based on scale of one to ten
leagues only exists for women there's no
one to ten for guys it's either you you
got it or you don't got it there's no
such thing don't believe that or else
you're never gonna [ __ ] tens and you're
gonna get nervous you're gonna get
nervous around hot woman she's out of my
league that [ __ ] has no personality you
can make a girl laugh you already got
your foot in the door it's just a girl
at the end of the day you can't be that
scared to go up it's just a girl it's
just a bride at the end of the day yeah
if this is a natural thing how come i'm
with like in college and i'm with a girl
who's like you know good girlfriend or
whatever nothing crazy is a college
girlfriend i'm like i want to cheat all
the time i just want to keep cheating
and then before
like when i would do that people feel
like oh you're just immature you need to
settle down you need to settle down you
need it's like neutering a dog you don't
want him to keep humping the but that's
naturally what a dog is a dog humps the
pillow a dog humps a leg but you want to
domesticate it so you cut the walls
right off the dog
i agree in a different way i think
settling down isn't necessarily like
cutting the balls off in the aspect that
you can't sleep with other people but i
think it is in the aspect that you can't
go out and um have as many adventures
and stuff once you get married and
settle down so you can have i feel like
it's more like a while you have some
adventures once you're married no i i
don't think like the trap of getting
married is that like you can't sleep
with other women i see it more as when
you get married like i see all these
married dudes and they're like depressed
that they didn't do more and that they
just like they felt pressured to get to
get married to this woman and it's like
why why are you even getting married in
that case
we talked about this like what is the
real point of getting married the little
tax benefit and just getting the
government involved in your affairs like
i personally just don't understand that
i think it's weird i don't know some
people like it i i but like why what
what's the point like no one likes to go
like what do you like the government
enough to have enough to get involved in
your love life like what is the point
it's weird yeah they're involved in your
money affairs which they already are
involved in it's all about if you really
find somebody that you believe you want
to build a life with and build your
future with and a family with people
have all those feelings and they want to
act on them this guy if he's in college
and he just wants to
bed hop cool have at it but don't lie to
your girlfriend just break up with her
or tell her the truth have some
integrity i think he i think he i don't
know if he's calling it cheating it's
it's not it it's not in the light of day
so that it's like
just doing what you want to do more
obedient no i want my balls i want to
keep [ __ ] i'm not a bad person
because i want to cheat that's something
natural and if you're a man who's like
oh i never think about any other and
this is the last [ __ ] i want to kiss
you're a [ __ ] liar
he's not wrong he's really not everybody
looks at other
other fruit on the vine
that's haram if a woman does it haram
this is haram
haram send her to saudi have you been in
a regular relationship before yeah they
didn't last long though that was the big
one with the my girlfriend before was
like i wanted to cheat all the time
because she went to a different college
she's wrong
being honest
let me explain to you look they say
you're doing long distance though it's
not oh
i was living in long island she was
living in brooklyn and it's like it's 40
minutes
minutes yeah
that shouldn't be the excuse she's she's
a 30 minute she's 30 minutes away what
do you expect listen this is the guy
that would cheat if she lived next door
no yeah i'm saying that's that should be
your point not for because she lives 40
minutes away
and i'm sure he was open with the girls
about it and that's why they broke up
but who knows he could have just gotten
caught i think he got caught maybe the
way
train ride
i was on long island she's in brooklyn
there's nothing to say about that i'm
just glad you showed me that that was
fun yeah that's funny
bro
stop encouraging the whole face stop
letting women run around and think that
they can sleep around the same way you
sleep around women don't earn their
whole face you know what they do to do a
whole phase
oh face
you spread your legs
men have to earn it you need to what
i've been saying something to be a whole
they'll be like why can i be a hoe like
you huh huh
because i needed to be the [ __ ] to be a
hoe to sleep around i need to be the
[ __ ] man this is what i was saying in
the interviews in my last video a girl
could be a two instead of sleep with 20
guys but if a guy's a two he's lucky if
he ever even touches a girl yeah to get
to 20 that guy's got to kidnap them no
he's got a he's got to go bill cosby on
them we're not we're just for the record
not encouraging that
unless you're a two and you got it
from a joker
dude i mean i i just think he's an
[ __ ] like i yeah yes you don't like
myself
you also don't why you don't husband up
that's not an expression but you don't
marry like a cheating
gigolo either unless you want an open
marriage and you agree to that in
advance the whole cheating thing that
they're talking about i think it's more
reasonable if it's agreed upon and
you're not just doing it behind her back
because that's just not cool to the girl
they're feminizing men
and they're masculinizing women they're
separating gender everybody thinks
there's no gender roles everybody thinks
that everybody's equal and it's turning
people crazy 95 percent of people all
think the same things they all echo what
they're telling you to echo most people
are brainwashed
when you clip up the stuff and then you
post it you're going to see everyone
like this guys that he used to grow up
just chill out what is he why is this
guy saying it it was funny if i was a
white guy they would just call me all
right but i'm not which is kind of a
privilege in a sense because i'm mixed i
could talk about like bringing back some
traditional values i could talk about
bringing back gender roles and they
don't know what to call me think how is
it yes he has a team he can talk about a
lot more because of his race which is
pretty nice which is nice everything he
just said i could not agree with more
the brainwashing thing too it is pretty
crazy because everyone stares at their
phones for 10 hours a day so there
really is only so much that you can
truly have as original thoughts when you
have other people's thoughts portrayed
on you all day like sometimes i sit
there and i'm thinking like is this
really what i'm thinking and how i feel
or was this just like portrayed on to me
from social media it would be cool if
people were watching videos on how to
think and how to make up your own mind
and you know it also comes down to like
the system doesn't teach you how to
think it teaches you how to follow
systems and become a slave a slave to
the systems yeah totally i don't know i
just i just want to reiterate his point
about their feminine they're trying so
hard to feminize men i knew men who went
to those [ __ ] hat marches and
and i just thought like what are you
doing you are such a [ __ ] bro go get
something why do you yeah you're not
proving anything and that was all
because
maybe if i wear enough if i walk enough
with my vagina hat on maybe i'll get
some ass did you actually think that was
going to bring more respect to women as
a man or a woman walking around
i was embarrassed for everybody that did
that the family court system is biased
against men false fraternity false
accusations prison sentencing disparity
failure in education health issues and
male abuse yes why do you think that so
many people aren't aware of men's issues
if a man is a victim of domestic
violence or domestic abuse he's not
going to report it to the police and if
you call the police they'll arrest you
exactly in that same exact scenario when
there's domestic violence going on you
just need to bob and weave
take all the punches and the shoving and
all the craziness and you have to just
suck it up
because you'll never win nobody will
take it seriously the cops will laugh at
you the court will laugh at you the
girl's always the victim even if she
puts your hands on you
nowadays girls will put your hands on
you now duh duh girls will shut up
that's why it was nice seeing johnny
depp finally take a w against all the
wonderful [ __ ] so i mean you definitely
agree with that girls lie [ __ ] okay
when they had that whole belief all
women [ __ ] going on i was furious
people who voted for biden like do you
really does anyone in the chat talk to
me who who here like voted for biden is
like yeah biden's a good president
nobody he just looks like at least he's
not trump
at least he's not trump and bro he
doesn't even talk
he doesn't speak he doesn't do anything
name one thing check name one it is
honestly sad he's an 80 year old man he
should be eating pudding and watching tv
chocolate chocolate chip oh yeah not
running a country it's like it genuinely
makes me sad that he's in the position
he's in it's it's not just his age it's
his it's his condition because they're
80 year olds that are sharp as tax and
can run [ __ ] better than anybody but
this guy 80 year olds this is ridiculous
any grandparents i talk to yeah i love
getting like hearing their old stories
and stuff but how are these people
running the country like running the
country i'm sad for him because i feel
that he's just a pawn he's not running
the country if anyone thinks he's
actually running the country they're
mistaken and he's right no one actually
likes
by to noah i mean everything he said
he'd do he did the opposite and then
that's why people are going to get so
excited oh my god the new the elections
are coming up i can't wait for the
debates i'm so excited to see what
political views they have to say and the
changes they're going to make no they
don't even make the changes they're
going to say in the debates it's all
about winning the
one president who did just about
everything he promised was donald trump
he came in and he started checking all
his boxes biden is trying to get his
agenda done but it's so terrible that he
can't get it done even though he he owns
the whole god and then the [ __ ]
instagram stories are going to be coming
soon with the change.org and all the
girls are going to be political
activists i'm going to have to delete
instagram when that happens yep american
gen z they literally want society to
crumble they want the whole [ __ ] tear it
all down and start from the top abolish
what you're not gen z i am gen z okay
please
delete the government just start over
like what what
i think
i can't believe that this was like
actually going on on social media like
people were saying this [ __ ] i think
that's where we hit like the stupidest
level in american history yes that's
about you please let's put all our money
to the government therapist how could
that possibly be that possibly how the
government you can't even get a driver's
license for three weeks let alone if
you're in trouble you trust the
government a government therapist i want
them to run as little as possible as
little as possible yeah i love when they
when we said social worker through
domestic violence we act like the big
issue with the police is them being
racist when it's just them being
[ __ ] half the time well no no i
don't like that at all how
that's that's the real problem with the
police they make it seem like they're
big they make mistakes but to say
they're [ __ ] half the time is just a
mischaracterization and again not based
on data so the whole problem
is that these people refuse to look at
data you show them data that counteracts
their point and they just
explode if you look back through history
there are people who were quote unquote
progressives and they made huge leaps
and bounds
for humanity like you know getting rid
of slavery you know creating freedom
setting up freedom like in france and
all these places and on and on and on
way back to biblical times people who
moved humanity forward these people have
taken
the term progressive and ruined it it
was a good thing
now progressive equals illogical
nonsense and that's all it is and it's a
shame this guy is totally right
abolishing 100 percent if you go into
the communities and ask the people
do you want to abolish the police the f
all of them are like hell no how are we
gonna abolish the police and replace it
with what i don't know therapist what
are you talking about
if i get shot i'm gonna call a therapist
yeah call four one one nine nine one one
what are you talking about
just pair the whole sh
there's a whole
demographic that wants this to burn to
the ground yeah you know what though all
those dumb [ __ ] are still going to
call 9-1-1 when something goes wrong and
they'll grow up and they'll change their
mind yeah there was a telling comment
that we had in a conversation the other
night do you remember you somebody was
telling you that you should move to
california and and you said would you
say i was like too liberal dude and the
taxes you said it's two left and they
your first thing was it was two left and
they went they were shocked and offended
and then they go you're so young to
think it's two left as if we're like too
young they know that young people are
going to be left and then they're going
to grow up and get logical brains and
move to the right because logic takes
over at some point
why would i want to live in california
right now that sounds horrible you were
born much rather that's it you got out
you escaped and then when i went back
for those of you guys that don't know i
was born in san francisco and i lived
there for about three months
and then
when i went back when i was like 13
i'm f i'm walking around and i see a
homeless dude butt naked with only a
sock over his speech i do the whole city
smells like pee
why is that the most expensive city in
the country well i don't think it is
anymore but um that makes no sense it's
it's always one or two new york and san
francisco yeah eastern europe 20 30
years ago [ __ ]
now it's the best place in the world
california 20 30 years ago greatest
place ever it's the worst place ever now
it's just a wasteland if you go to l.a
bro no one's even looking at each other
they're just making tick-tock they're
dancing on the street they're bringing
ring lights on the beach it's already
sunny yeah i would never want to live in
la i hated l.a 25 years ago i hated it i
thought it was a soulless horrible place
well
that's it that's it
all right
you know sneakers you got to give them
you got to give them the one the one out
of 10 rating so i like him he's got a
cute little face he looks like somebody
you know he's just look at him he's got
a mama's boy face he's a sweetheart he's
a pumpkin he's all full of [ __ ] on these
videos that kid's at home giving his mom
a hugs nikko nothing wrong with giving
your mom a hug you still speak his mind
so what do you give him one out of ten
you don't make me mad sneakers before
you got an h nicole you gotta learn more
about it you gotta come over for dinner
sneakers nate listen tate tate really
upset me with that funeral thing okay
sneaker i give people a lot of credit
and a lot of a lot of leeway and he
didn't say anything that infuriated me
like that not going to foster you know
come on you still get on a goddamn plane
and you go to your father's funeral yeah
that was we need to know more about him
though i'm sure if we get enough into
him he'll make me mad that really sets
you off the track that set me up i think
sneko could benefit from having
integrity with his woman the way tate
does though maybe they should talk have
they talked
it's nico and tate i don't think so i'm
sure they will soon though they're both
blowing up crazy right now i'd like for
them to talk about integrity yeah
i'd like the both of their takes on
integrity because sneaker does not seem
to think it matters but tate lives in
integrity why do you think sneko doesn't
think integrity matters because he just
cheats
so does tate no
tate sits from town and says this house
gonna be
i guess we don't know enough about
though as he said you can come to the
top of the mountain or you can you know
beat feet whatever but
this guy is lying
lying to the girl why are you wearing
any of your [ __ ] cuz why are you
lying and she's just cause she's in
brooklyn i'm from brooklyn
i just do not like to be like 30 minutes
old
she lives like 30 minutes away what am i
supposed to do hey guys listen
like like subscribe
sonny's given a hundred bucks to
somebody that what is it
all right you think what are they gonna
do they're gonna dm you on instagram
they gotta like subscribe and dm you on
instagram with proof with proof and you
get 100 bucks
yeah someone's getting 100 bucks i am
ineligible and it's not right because i
would do it but you know what you do it
get the hundred bucks
and i want to know so i can call
everyone a brokey no no wait and i want
to know what they spent it on you wanna
know what they spend the hundred bucks
on i hope you spent it on your mother
all right guys love you
[Music]
long
peace